bom dia como está o programa vai hoje à
meia noite foi um pouco especial com
toda imaginar porque ela sente tantas
emoções com com a histeria com este
momento é bastante fantásticas tão
fantástica quanto o medo o medo deste
palco o medo eu vou ter a minha frente
o medo de de falar uma língua que não é
a minha língua materna
começa agora que já vos disse
eu falei do meu medo era eu que estou
pronta para vos contar e partilhar a
minha história no ano em que eu fiquei a
29 anos
catherine da da competição
foi uma vida dedicada ao treino de judo
e quase uma década
competindo alto nível o que começou com
voltem a 6 anos com uma simples prática
esportiva para o outro passar a minha
timidez é fomos construindo como pessoa
é do comer um esforço é na disciplina na
excelência durante muitos anos de de
praticado esportiva tv
a sorte de conseguir o sonho é de todos
os desportistas é o sonho de chegar a
uns jogos olímpicos é é uma vivência
grandiosa os jogos
é um momento da nossa vida em que
sentimos que estamos a escrever nosso
nome no mil da história da humanidade é
um reconhecimento uma vida de esforço de
treino de sacrifício de muita competição
ao longo desta desta vida é de treino e
competição
experimentamos muitas emoções muitas
emoções muitas vezes sentimos que
vivemos constantemente é como se
tivéssemos uma montanha russa
sentimos vez muita felicidade outras
vezes muita tristeza ea euforia medo
medo medo muitas vezes cada vez que
enfrentamos um torneio sentimos medo e
temos medo de dizer que temos medo é
porque mesmo uma palavra terrível é uma
palavra que deixem de oliveira deixando
entrever as nossas fraquezas mas todos
nos sentimos mesmo quem não sente medo
em não deixa de ser corajoso quem não
sente medo ou cria vencido pelo menos
deixa de ser corajoso quem sente medo e
não vai à luta que antes de avançar 2
teu novo e no momento que temos eu não
vou
estamos a perder uma oportunidade
desafio que havia danos nos brindou o
momento em que nos mostraria vida nos
mostraria que sempre podemos muito mais
do que pensamos que podemos
no ano 2000 é o ano
a minha participação nos jogos olímpicos
é assim né
encontrei nenhuma situação com uma
circunstância uma colega de equipa de
competir na mesma categoria de peso do
que eu
conseguiu o apuramento olímpico um
campeonato no uso é só é permitido a
participação de woods doca por país e
por peso nos jogos olímpicos
como ele já tinha conseguido o
apuramento e fica lá fora
foram momentos é frustração de tristeza
de pensar e agora aqui agora que agora
para mim o meu momento
mexe quando uma porta se fecha
temos que ter visão e esperança em que
outras se pode abrir decidir e não fui
eu só ajudo como treinador porque não
tentarmos competir em uma teoria é cima
é teoria pensadas mais 68 quilos na
categoria acima é não sou e o devia
aumentar o meu penso que não foi fácil
eu pensava 75 quilos deverá atingir um
mínimo 88 quilos se saem para poder
pensar no e permitirem participar
eu também iria encontrar enfrentar os
judocas com 30 40 50 quilos mais do que
eu posso vos dizer que lutei com alguma
quer ter medo aplicava o preço
imagino que agora podem podem ver o o
meu medo não o mesmo que eu sentia medo
de magoar no sentido de me machucar em
deter do física realmente avançar
eu vou tentar eu vou tentar
é só ter é a de estar da minha parte
ele é amor que elaborámos um um trabalho
um plano para é iniciada este novo
desafio um trabalho que isso pulso uma
adaptação do meu treino da minha mãe era
surdo da minha alimentação e comentário
peço é é um trabalho de psicológico não
é o que que o iria pôr na minha cabeça
para me convencer que conseguiriam
enfrentar e vencer judocas muito mais
força do que o muito mais pesadas no que
eu sabem que o sudão é uma palavra
japonesa que significa caminho da sua
vida
indicando o caminho da não resistência
isso que devia fazer novo estilo eu eu
sabia que eu estava em feriado física
mas pensar em bonn
agora eu não posso enfrentar a força
dela mas eu tenho que me beneficiar da
força que elas querem projetar sobre mim
para ceder a essa força provocar um
desequilíbrio e conseguir derrubá las e
assim como nos ajuda na vida a dois anos
atrás no ano 2016 com um pouco mais de
40 anos surgiu num mil cópias
uma coleção com a de que no duro penso
que até então dado aqui no portal da
minha na meia esquerda
foram as mais sensíveis do meu marido
que se aperceberam da sua presença
porque não tinha nada por nada
ian e insistiu para que o médico vai a
um médico é sam está buscando culpados
não é que a interface ao médico nem o
mais importante na nossa vida
mas ele insistiu tanto tanto tanto que é
também por um médico porque num não
queria que ele se esquecer que esse mais
manter consulta fez uma ecografia e este
médico e com deus né não estou a ver
isto muito claro por favor vamos repetir
ecografia no trânsito com outro médico
seja consultado estava entanto outro dia
10 que tiver tempo vou marcar editar
consulta para tanto porque é que o
grafeno
sem querer dar demasiada importância a
situação podia estar a correr no meu
trailer num cêntimo à amputação como
efeito parado e pensei para mim me
trecho vai marcar essa ecografia agora
mesmo porque a ecografia com o médico
que este primeiro médico marcar comentou
o irmão segunda grafia um médico diz né
de turismo vou fazer aqui uma via
próxima
aqui mesmo e agora uma biopsia sabem que
consiste em introduzir uma agulha enorme
dentro da meta retirar uma amostra para
vai analisar é feito quando este se em
quase não dói mas às vezes também dois
dias depois foi buscar os resultados
quando estou no botão enfermeira que é
ajudava wellington aproxi mostra e disse
me por favor não vai morar aqui é um
erro querer falar consigo
aí comecei a pensar
foi muito difícil você com grafias mesma
via obscena enfermeiro vai permitir
embora
vamos ver o que é o que tem para me
dizer que entrei na consulta um de jogar
pensando que estava preparada para ouvir
o que o médico tivesse para merecer e
limeira civil com um sorriso muito
carinhoso sul eu também sou rei nunca
ter essa o risco mas comecei a sentir
nas plantações do meu coração
além disso havia a opção deu positivo
3 um tumor na mama neste momento
[Música]
centenas quer que o mundo tá era como se
fosse um filme e que trás como se fosse
um filme mas não podem porque é a
realidade porque eu porque mim porque o
que eu fiz
só uma pessoa mais ou menos saudável foi
o esportista porque é repente ter
sentido que que a vida estava nas mãos e
se as mãos tão fortes que tenha lutado
contra mulheres e normas e ainda falta
na minha cabeça uma coisa mais dura do
que nada
é o meu filho eu tenho um filho pequeno
que ainda precisa de mim ainda não
acabei o meu trabalho correndo e eu não
posso ir embora eu ainda tenho que ficar
a minha missão não está concluída com
ela nessa estas coisas vão ao chão
não me interessa é uma coisa menor
tentando manter a calma tudo estava uma
consulta e não queria mostrar uma certa
fraqueza ouviu que o médico tinha para
me dizer dos passos que seriam ser
rapidamente marcamos uma ressonância
magnética
uma ressonância que viria a descobrir é
também existia outro tumor na outra mama
fizemos nove opção e confirmamos que
esse era um tumor que ainda não era mão
mas quem qualquer momento transformaria
mão por isso iria ser operada às duas
mamas e não só alma neste processo todo
o mais difícil para mim foi como dizer
às pessoas que a ela o que me estava a
suceder e o que mereço cedermos mercer
por isso pensei que tem de escolher com
muito cuidado
as palavras queriam os a para informar a
cada um de luz o que se ia passar comigo
os trailers um caminho suave para as
convencer me convencer a mim próprio de
que sairia vencedora desta circunstância
que tinha ocupado o caminho da minha
vida
as pessoas aqui me machucou mais duro
era noticiam fã dos meus pais é tenha
consciência estava consciente
como mãe quanto difícil seria para me
ouvir uma notícia como esta não é por
isso treinar em um discurso no mês
vezes até o momento que estou preparada
para dizer sem dramatismos
mas sabendo que é a dor é inevitável e
esse pouco a pouco fui dando a notícia
ana todos ao mesmo tempo que a notícia
tornava mais família
esta nova realidade e esta foi a minha
primeira estratégia eu tudo em instantes
antes respeito proto moro mas não podia
ter medo porque iria estar comigo
através da cirurgia que o tirassem de
mim o dia o tempo que passou entre entre
é a confirmação do tumor e ea cirurgia
não foi mais do mesmo mas parece uma
eternidade um mês dedicado a fazer
muitos exames muitas ainda esperam até a
ter muita papelada mais indicada pensar
a aceitar e colocar cada pensamento
nesse lugar
isso foi é minha segunda estratégia
eu não podia tirar o tumor dentro de mim
isto era um trabalho queria fazer os
médicos mas sim podia começar a
trabalhar na minha da cooperação mesmo
culto nome lá dentro é esse seria o meu
o tivo estava habituado a treinar para
os motivos de competição mas agora eles
teriam o objetivo de vida e como atingir
o meu objetivo com a minha de tudo
elaborei um plano de treino atitude um
plano de treino começou por esquecer o
tumor no iapar eu não lhe tocava era
como se ão lá já não estivesse depois
também precisava de ter atividade física
não podia fazer uso do dia
e caminhar rápido rápido ea ump do marão
e foi ao ginásio sentir o chorume papel
da ami força fazendo sentir muito forte
faz eu me sentir viva e em ocupava o meu
tempo em olhar para a frente
no passar por vítima de uma doença que
poderia matar passava o tempo a pensar a
sorte que eu tinha de ter a minha volta
tantas pessoas que cuidavam nenê que
cuida do meu coração que me mandava
mensagens mostrava a morte da amiga nos
abraços enviam flores
estou foi muito importante na minha vida
por tudo o que me estava a dar o futebol
venha da cirurgia um dia que me sentir
feliz despertar e feliz da manhã e de
ser coxa vai sair de mim quando ocorreu
a cirurgia o tumor já não estava comigo
assim tenha duas costuras enfeitinhos
que passaria a formar parte da história
da minha vida depois da cirurgia
depois de acompanhar a cirurgia é
tamanha receber tratamento de
radioterapia
cada vez que é um cada vez que é ea o
iptu para os tratamentos às vezes
passava pelo parque é e infantil via
crianças crianças que é que encontraram
uma pedra no seu caminho de uma cela
serão crianças sorridentes as crianças
estavam a brincar as crianças que
mostraram que a vida entre a ser vivida
não importa quanto de longa o
ou seja temos que viver e temos de viver
com o sorriso porque com um sorriso é
muito mais fácil é verdade que é
tentei não acabar me a parte negativa de
toda esta circunstância para que decidir
viver cada um dos três dias desde dentro
do coração porque cada dia tem uma
mensagem torneio mensal passar palavra
porque há muitas pessoas pedindo ajuda
para mandar embora os pensamentos que
não queria derrotar sua consciência que
partir para este combate com vantagem o
uso do emf nome é levantar me cada vez
que caía
ensinou-me asseverou o medo para
conseguir vencer
foi isso planeta por um rival que não
conhecia mas sabia que todos os rivais
mesmos muito fortes porém ser derrotadas
e para derrotar tenha de utilizar com
inteligência as minhas ferramentas e
ferramenta mais poderosa que eu tinha e
que todos nós temos só os meus
pensamentos em nosso coração eo nosso
pensamento nosso coração que vão
determinar a nossa tudo por isso vamos
treinar nossa atitude mostramos aqui
tudo para lidar com estas circunstâncias
que encontramos no nosso caminho
vamos mudar a nossa atitude para sermos
mais felizes e por isso quero vos deixar
a frança que adotei para a minha vida
a nossa atitude é nossa escolha
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]